[Music]
hi I'm Hannah and I am a busy lady as a
working mom with two kids I feel like I
have more commitments than the average
person this week I am living with zero
extra commitments just like 18 t prepaid
and I could not be more excited so on
Monday I met Mae and she was totally
amazing that day were several
brainstorms that I had volunteered to
lead may hit the ground running just
helping me out so I was able to take
that time and try meditating at my
office so on Tuesday make him over to my
house she made this epic breakfast and
ended up packing all the lunches so I
could go back to bed that morning then
when the kids left for school I had the
whole morning to just get myself looking
nice I tried a new makeup routine I
tried doing my hair I dressed nicely I
just felt really good going into the day
the next day Mae came to work with me
and took on some more work commitments
she had one-on-ones with my direct
reports so I went out to lunch this is
something I have never done hi mom no I
know I am at work I'm actually at lunch
today so I figured I would just give you
a call I felt like a new woman comes
back into the office at the end of my
long lunch then when I got home Mae had
already made cupcakes that I had agreed
to make for Jackson's bake sale at
school and folded all of my laundry
there's a nice so on Thursday May took
on a task that I had been putting off
for a little while which was hemming
Wyatt's pants and embellishing his best
for his spring performance so having her
take it on and just giving me that free
time to actually spend with the kids was
so incredible I love this too so not
only did may take the dogs out of the
house so that I could have just an hour
to a piece she washed my car and cleaned
my bathroom so I took that time to work
out something that I very rarely do then
because I'm all about healthy balance I
climbed into bed and snapped on some
cheese I can't think of a better hobby
so Saturday the kids had a birthday
party to go to and kids birthday parties
at this age are actually a huge or
to y'all because I have to get the gift
get the gift ready and actually be
present at the party the entire time
with my kids I actually don't mind going
to kids birthday parties but if
somebody's gonna take that on I'm not
going to say no I took that opportunity
to just give myself an at-home spa day
nice fancy bath lounged around in my
bathrobe and it was truly wonderful so
Sunday is my errand day and I was able
to spend some quality time with my kids
while Mae did stuff around the house was
that fun yes babes so this week was just
like my AT&T prepaid there's no annual
contract no commitment and it doesn't
feel like I'm signing my life away but I
still get unlimited talk and text and
high-speed data and this is the best way
for us to save money every month so I
can have more at home spa days for
myself